مرحباً بالجميع مرحباً كيكي ، كيف حالك كانت
كيكي ناج تطبخ بالفعل
وجبة عيد الشكر لمجموعة كبيرة من
الأصدقاء لماذا كل شيء أصعب بكثير
بعد
الوباء لقد نسيت كيفية القيام بذلك ولكنها
أرادت أيضًا أن تفتح منزلها في لوس أنجلوس
لبعض  من بين أحدث المقيمين في البلاد ،
تطوعت في
منظمة تسمى Mary's List التي
تساعد اللاجئين على الاستقرار في الولايات المتحدة ،
لقد قمت للتو برميها إلى Mary مثل
هل تعرف أي عائلة أفغانية
تحتاج إلى أول عيد شكر مع
عائلة أمريكية ، ولذا قالت  نعم ،
لماذا لا تدعو وحيدًا ، مرحباً بالجميع ،
كيف حالك ، تخبرنا وحيدة أزكري أنه
كان مترجمًا ومترجمًا فوريًا
للجيش الأمريكي في أفغانستان ، وصل
في أواخر عام 2020 مع أطفاله الأربعة
بموجب تأشيرة هجرة خاصة ،
انضمت إليهم زوجته بعد خمسة أشهر  كانت هذه
أول دعوة للعائلة
لتناول وجبة عيد الشكر التقليدية في بعض الأحيان
نود أن نسألك ما هو
الديك الرومي الذي قلته إن الديك الرومي يشبه الدجاج المخبوز
الذي يصنعه نج  بالتأكيد سيكون هناك على الأقل
شيئًا مألوفًا على الطاولة ، هذا
هو المصباح ، مرحبًا ،
هذه التجربة لم تكن فقط حول الأطعمة الجديدة ،
بل إنها أرجوانية ، بل كانت أيضًا تتعلق بتعلم
تقليد مشاركة الامتنان ، فقد يكون لدينا المزيد من
الفرص في حياتنا في أيدينا ،
لذلك
بالطبع
المثال الأهم هو أننا نجتمع
مع عائلتنا وتأجيل تأشيرة زوجته
، يقول إنهم محظوظون لأنها وصلت
قبل الخروج الفوضوي للقوات الأمريكية في أغسطس ، حيث
كان مشهد الأشخاص الذين يحاولون الفرار
يتردد صداها بشكل خاص مع
ضيف الشكر توم  فان تران بشكل جيد
عندما رأيت صورة الأفغان في
طائرة الشحن ، ذكّرتني
كثيرًا بالسبب وراء تواجدها في نفس المكان ، لكنها
كانت سفينة شحن عملاقة أتت
إلينا كلاجئ من فيتنام في
عام 1975 عندما كان  في نفس عمر
أكبر أطفال أصغري ، يقول إنه يستطيع أن
يقدم صداقة أخوية ترحيبية
دافئة ويمكنه أن يتخيل ما
قد يواجهونه عندما
وصلت منذ عام تقريبًا مثل في  العديد من
تجمعات العطلات لا يمارس الجميع هنا
نفس الدين أو لديهم
نفس المعتقدات السياسية على الرغم من أن
هناك شيئًا أساسيًا
للتجربة الأمريكية
متجذر في الامتنان
المتجذر
في التطوع الذي
تغادر بلدك وتترك الموقف
وتأتي إلى هنا  في بعض الأحيان مع القليل جدًا في بعض
الأحيان مع عدم وجود شيء ، وتبدأ
من جديد ، يطلب askari من أطفاله العمل بجد
لاغتنام هذه الفرصة ، نحن هنا من
أجلك والولايات المتحدة هنا من
أجلك وكل ما لديك في
يدك ما ستفعله هو لديك
لدراسة هذا الأمر بدءًا بما
يأمل ناج أنه درس من أول
عيد شكر لهم ، أريدهم أن يروا
أن هذا النوع من التسامح ممكن حقًا
في الولايات المتحدة ، حيث إن
الأمريكيين هم في القلب حقًا شعب كريم.